okay so I went to this religious school
from the time I was four years old until
I graduated high school and it was
extremely controlling and like all of
the things that I loved to do were
against the rules like we weren't
allowed to dance and like there was no
like physical touch between any of the
children and like music was one of my
deep loves and rock music was completely
against the rules and if they caught you
like dancing or playing rock music and
you could suffer punishments like you
could be expelled or suspended so for
most of my youth life I felt extremely
judged every day I feel judged a lot as
an older person for one there's the
assumption that I don't know anything
about technology when I went into the
library to look for a book the fellow
said dude are you on the computer and
I've been on the computer since 1992
like some things they talk to you really
simply and loudly like you can't hear
you can't understand and then you go out
and people smile at you you know in a
certain way
look at that old lady and the kids don't
see people with gray hair any worse and
he stare at you you know there's a lot
of judgments that you have to be careful
of like that that's a big reason for
senior isolation I just don't want to
have another conversation where Who I am
inside of what I look like outside it
was a big big difference you know so it
was this time where like people started
going through puberty and stuff and me
and my friends decided to go to the
public swimming pool and like everyone
started getting changed and stuff and
there were like guys that were looking
from afar and me and my girlfriends we
were like getting changed and I like
started to see that I wasn't like the
thinnest girl and so I was like feeling
a bit fat and then the other girls they
were like yeah we should go and talk to
the guys and stuff and I felt like
really insecure because I didn't feel
like comfortable I my body and the guys
were like staring at me and I like felt
like really bad because
they will like the beautiful girls and I
feel like far in between them so yeah
being an interracial couple we get
judged a lot and being in public not
everywhere we've been but we have been
in the past in heaven too interracial
children and we do kind of get frowned
on but we overlook it and we feel that
it's their issue not ours so will
purposely smooch in public and just show
lots of love because we're a loving
family
[Music]
so I've been working in tech for almost
six years and some of my earlier stops
there's like this pressure to drink and
because of my faith I don't and I felt
like if I said no or didn't appear in
bars and stuff I was being super judged
I personally feel like it impacts
advancement like you know a lot of
promotions or project coordination
happens in these kinds of meetings and
if you're saying hey I don't take
partake in that then it limits your
opportunity to advance so that's one
thing that I personally felt on a few
occasions it was sixth grade I was
bringing like I think it was like a
right like yellow nail polish and then
this girl was like oh I think that color
doesn't and I was like Oh what do you
mean she's like oh like you're too dark
for that skin color and I don't know it
just made me feel really bad it was one
of the first times where like someone
made a comment like that like above my
skin color I was like what do you mean
like anyone can wear this color you know
like I feel like maybe it's those same
kind of people who feel like oh that's
that doesn't go with your skin color
then it's like when they grow up like
they kind of portray that in Maggie
it makes you realize that people are
kind of racist sometimes without them
even knowing um I got a new coat I was
in probably fifth grade and I got new
pair of boots and I was really excited
about them and I went to school and
these girls so that they're really ugly
and they made me look really bad and
when I went home and I started to cry
because I felt really self-conscious and
like judged because of who I am and I
was trying to like express Who I am with
my clothes or something and I felt
really judged my mom talked to me about
it and just said be yourself and show
who you really are even if that if you
get judged for it or people who are mean
to you
when like I went from like a multiracial
elementary school to like a white middle
school and like I just felt like I had
like everyone was like looking at me
because if I was like a different skin
color so I guess I've always struggled
with like a skin color and stuff so like
I felt judged in middle school people
call me like Harambee and stuff but I
was just like like I'm feel attacked
feel like I never like show that to them
but they bothered me you know like but
like I know like whatever they say it
isn't matter less I'm okay with myself
so I had just moved from my hometown and
I went to a different school where
everybody was just like really had a lot
of new brand clothes and everything and
I didn't have anything like that because
my mom didn't have the money for it so I
since I didn't have any of that stuff I
felt less of a person and like I should
have that stuff and I just felt
everybody was attacking me because
probably when I opened up to my friends
I was a raging alcoholic
[Music]
I'm only 21
so here one doesn't when I shared my
position on same-sex marriage
so what happen exactly I was living that
lifestyle and for you know quite a few
years and then
and I found my way back to God and I
said I just need to be honest with you
and let you know I'm not going to be
voting that way and I get stood my
position and I was verbally attacked and
so then it was it ended a relationship
for a while but in time I did you know
renew that relationship with the main
individual I think I would feel the most
judged better I've felt the most judged
on the internet or social media or
something where you're posting yourself
or your thoughts or your pictures of
your own face and you're putting it out
there for people to judge it you know
like like or dislike so that never has
made me feel good ever even even when
they're liking it or it's in a positive
way so I got rid of social media and
getting rid of social medias freedom
from that crazy judgment that doesn't
need to happen that validation that
feels so unnecessary that you just need
to give yourself
the time I vote most judge was probably
growing up when I was a ballet dancer
and being there I was always the tallest
and like the biggest girl so I always
felt judged like just being in that room
for many years and kind of did something
to my self-esteem that you know that was
when I felt was Judge it was funny
because when I like hit puberty at like
11 12 years old I lost a lot of weight
like really rapidly and I could like
physically see how people's reaction to
be different to me like the teacher
teach was so much nicer to me just
because I was you know a lot more skinny
than before it made me realize that
people did treat me different if I
looked a certain way so I kind of like
pressured myself to look you know to
basically almost like on the verge of
like an eating disorder because people
treated me so much better when I was
thinner than and I was a lot bigger I
think that being a single mother right
now it's hard to like figure out where I
sit right is it with all of the rest of
the mothers and the people who are
married or is it with the
I'm just kind of in most like the
awkward transfer I don't really know
what like table to sit at or where I'm
invited to anymore I'd like to sit at
any table that I'm welcome done there
you go after having to move to a
location where I was literally one of
maybe three Hispanic people let alone
like there was like ten colored people
in the entire school so it was a very
like 360 like flip from what I like grew
up with any time we would like walk into
like me my family would walk into any of
the stores like the staff would always
follow us around and trail us and they'd
be watching us and make sure that we're
not like like stealing things people
would say very racist comments stuff I
don't really want to repeat but you know
this is just like normal it was normal
for them I guess to say these kinds of
things it wasn't normal for me to hear
because I grew up in a very diverse area
and that just
isn't that the way we spoke to people
not things we heard from people this is
a really bad answer to like a very
serious question but the moment I put
the most judged was when I rewatched
lost for the third time and this guy was
like that's nine seasons how can you do
that and I took his losses a waste of
time
in row 9 it took nine years of my life
and I can't get those nine years back
wasn't when I when I was elementary
school I uh I tried to get out of band
practice once okay I did a bathroom and
my teacher wouldn't let me and so I was
just kept on raising my hands like can I
go to the bathroom please she's like no
I was like okay so you know I ended up
pissing my pants and I just like just
pissed my pants I didn't say like that
and she's like all right just go just go
luckily I had black pants on so this
isn't like noticeably like you know
pissy but yeah I knew that noon everyone
was laughing at me after that and
besides that I can't think of another
time that I've been judged terribly
although I'm pretty sure I get judged
every day I think now I mean I judge
myself now right
I mean how I how I am how I how I
interface with world with the world
right I want to make sure I'm right
right I want to walk upright I want to
be right so I want to be proper and so
yeah would you say that you're kind with
your judgement of yourself or pretty
harsh
I could be both when I got tattooed when
I talked about it with some friends they
were like you I never expected it from
you
so I was like oh well I like them but if
you don't then sorry it's my choice
can you show us your tattoo we're sure
in actually there are six now this was
the first one it's with my boyfriend are
you still with them yeah
[Music]
what is that one thing it's Chava Rita
even my nickname in my sister's
handwriting
what's that one this reminds me of my
sister she passed away and this is the
year that she was born hi everyone
thanks for watching another episode
basically I just want to say welcome to
the new subscribers and to the
subscribers who have been with me for a
while I want to thank you for constantly
supporting my channel that's pretty much
it thank you guys again for everything
and I'll see you next week